تراوح المعارك مكانها على الارض والحلو
برايكيف قد يكون في تغيير موازين القوى في
الجو فمنذ التقدم الميداني الذي حققه
الجيش الاوكراني في مقاطعه خرسون جنوب
الشرقيه البلاد قبل نحو شهر لا تكاد
الجبهات الساخنه الاخرى تشهد اختراقات
كبيره وجوهريه لاي من الطرفين رغم تمكن
القوات الروسيه والانفصاليين المواليين
لها من تحقيق مكاسب ميدانيه في مقاطعه
دونيه فضل العلم
حاليا يبدو منشغلا بالحصول على السلاح
النوعي جديد من الحديث والدعم الرئيسي
الاهم منذ اندلاع الحرب الحديث هنا عن
تزويد الامريكي المرتقبليكييف بمنظومه
صواريخ باتريوت الدفاع الجوي خطوه ان حصلت
ستمكن الاوكرانيين من التصدي بفعاليه اكبر
للضربات الصاروخيه والغا وهجمات المسيرات
التي تشنها موسكو بشكل شبه يومي وتستهدف
عاده منشات البنيه التحتيه الحيويه والتي
كان اخرها القصف العنيف الذي طال البنيه
التحتيه في خاركيف واستخدمت فيه روسيا
صواريخ اس 300 بحسب الجيش الاوكراني
كما ستمنح صواريخ باتريوت الفرصه للقوات
البريه الاوكرانيه للتحرك بحريه اكبر دون
القلق من الخطر القادم من السماء فاستعاده
الاراضي تجريب صعوبه كبيرا كما يقول
الرئيسكي بسبب التدمير الروسي المنهج
للمدن الاوكرانيه يقول مسؤولون امريكيون
ان واشنطن تضعوا لمساتها الاخيره على
الخطط الخاصه بتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ
باتريوت ولذلك سارعت موسكو عبر المتحدثه
باسم وزاره خارجيتها ماريا زخرفه بالتحذير
من ان المنظومه ستكون هدفا عسكريا مشروعا
للجيش الروسي وانها ستؤدي الى تصعيد
الصراع وتزيد من تورط الجيش الامريكي
المباشر في الاعمال القتاليه باكرانيا لكن
خطط الولايات المتحده لا تقتصر فقط على
تزويد الاوكرانيين بالصواريخ باتريوت
فبحسب مسؤولين امريكي فان
ستزود كيف بمعدات الكترونيه متطوره لتحويل
الذخائر الجويه غير الموجهه الى قنابل
ذكيه قادره على استهداف مواقع عسكريه
الروسيه بدقه